翻訳: Hiroyuki Sugiura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
昔むかし ある国に
男と女が住んでいました
この男女は夫婦でした
とっても仲が良い夫婦
妻の方はメッチャかわいいもんで
その国の王様は うらやましかった
したがって 王様は意地が悪くて
男から妻を奪い取りました
男は妻がいない生活 耐えられなくて
自殺しました
そして妻も
元旦那のことが大好きだったので
彼女も自殺しました
王様はブチ切れた
絶対あの夫婦は天国から見下ろして
俺様のことを馬鹿にしているに違いない
と王様は妄想しました
でもそこで王様は
とっても残酷なアイデアを考えました
王様はその夫婦の死体を
わざと離れ離れに
向かい合わせて
葬って墓を作りました
夫婦は 極めて近いものの
これで決して一緒になれません
王様 本当に根性悪
しかし その晩
突然ミラクル
両方の墓から木が生え
その木の枝が絡みあった
そして絡みあった枝の上に
オスとメスの鳥が巣を作って
悲しい声で鳴きました
かわいそうな夫婦のために
この鳥を
鴛鴦（おしどり） といいます
これは「鴛鴦夫婦」の元となった物語
鴛鴦はとても難しい漢字
この漢字 初めて見た人は？
おっ 結構います
（笑）
この漢字 正しく書ける自信のある人は？
じゃあ その前の物語
もう一度 振り返ってみよう
王様は怨みを抱いた
そして 夫婦を離れ離れに葬った
しかし その墓場の中央に
オスとメスの鳥が巣を作って
鳴きました
このストーリーを活用することで
この漢字を覚えられます
つまり
王様の「怨」みに対して
墓場の中「央」に
鳥が集まった
鴛鴦
これで わかりますか？
これから鴛鴦を書ける自信のある人は
ちょっと増えたでしょう
鴛鴦夫婦は 四字熟語のひとつです
四字熟語は 漢字検定１級に合格するには
およそ1000語も
覚えなくてはなりません
それに 鴛鴦のようなとっても難しい熟語が
沢山出題されます
漢字は猛勉強を求めます
しかし勉強はさすがに
つらいですね
どんだけ書き写しても
なかなか覚えられなくて
腱鞘炎を生じ
練習ノートの中
溺れるほど
難しいのです
だからこそ
遊び心をもって勉強すればいい
漢字は3000年前から今日に至って
常に進化してきたものです
漢字のストーリーで理解を深め
漢字の形をおもちゃとして遊び
楽しみながら勉強するのが
お薦めです
冒頭に紹介した「鴛鴦」
とても難しいですが
その鴛鴦のストーリーと形を活用したことで
もう皆さま鴛鴦はお手の物ですね
では椅子の下に問題用紙が配ってあります
取り出してください
（ざわつき）
いや 嘘 ジョークです
（笑）
そんな意地悪いことはしない
では次はもう少しなじみのある
漢字のストーリーを見てみよう
次は「羊羹」（ようかん）和菓子のひとつ
羊羹の「羊」は「ひつじ」のことですが
羹（かん）は困難ですね
分解してみると 仔羊＋美しい
羊羹は日本では
甘くておいしい和菓子のひとつですが
中国では 羊羹は昔
熱い羊のスープ
「羹（あつもの）に懲りて
膾（なます）を吹く」は その証拠です
羹（あつもの）と羹（かん）
漢字は一緒
これは羊羹の由来を表します
右手は現代の漢字
仔羊と美しい
左手はその漢字の元の形
この漢字を分解してみると
羊のスープの由来を語ります
下の方は調理に使う釜や鍋のこと
その鍋の上に仔羊があります
その仔羊の左右にある「弓」は
「湯気」スチームのことを表します
つまり この漢字は
「仔羊を鍋に入れて煮る」 という図形です
羊羹は もともと羊のスープ
ですが 日本に伝えた僧侶は
当時 肉食禁物なので
スープを冷たいゼリーに
そして羊の代わりに大豆を使いました
羊にとって本当に美しい話ですね
なぜなら 仔羊の命 大勢救いました
まさに 右手の現代の漢字のように
他にフルーツを表す漢字も難問です
でもこんな難しい漢字
その漢字の形を
おもちゃとをして遊ぶと誰でも書けます
簡単なものから入りましょう
林檎（りんご）
林檎は難しそうですが
分解してみると 朝飯前
林檎は
林の中で
木から 人が 離す
フルーツです
林檎は
林の中で
木から 人が 離す
果物
次は 味も漢字も顔をひそめる
檸檬（レモン）
檸檬は二文字あります
そして両方とも難しいです
でもこんな難しい漢字
檸檬を分解してみると
本当に お茶の子さいさい
では ここで檸檬を収穫する
檸檬ブラザーズを想像してみてください
弟は檸檬の管理をしています
兄は
「おい 檸檬の収穫はどうですか？」
と弟に尋ねると
弟は
「アニキ うっかり心緩めて
皿から１個下に落ちちゃった」
これに対して兄は怒りに震える
（兄）なんだと 早く檸檬の確認を！
（弟）アニキ 檸檬20個あったけど
わぁ １個豚に食べられちゃった
じゃあこの調子で もう１件
難読漢字を見てみよう
次は最強の四字熟語
魑魅魍魎（ちみもうりょう）
（笑）
魑魅魍魎は 様々な化け物という意味です
この恐ろしい魑魅魍魎でも
分解してみると ちょちょいのちょい
これは鬼退治の案内です
もし
鬼に
森の中で出会ったら
まず
離れて
そして
未然に用意した網で捕まえて
直ぐに両親へ報告する
（笑）
もし
鬼に
森の中で出会ったら
まず離れて
そして 未然に用意した網で捕まえて
直ぐに両親へ報告する
今まで楽しめましたか？
（拍手）
ありがとう
今日紹介したもの
ぜひ友達に教えて楽しませてください
そして思い出せなくても
自分のストーリーを作ってみてください
なんで漢字こんなに覚えたのか
私 高校生の時
日本のアニメーションを見て
漢字に興味を持ちました
仕事で日本に来て
漢字を沢山覚えたくなりました
そこで漢字検定の本を買いました
テスト概要のページに
各レベルの出題文字数が書いてあった
RPG（ロールプレイングゲーム）
好きな私は
ゲーム感覚でクリアしたくなりました
例えば
漢字そのものは経験値
級はレベル
10級は80字
５級は1006字
２級は2136字
そして１級は
なんと6000字
中高生時代にロールプレイングゲームを
やりまくった私にとって最高のシステム
最初は 喜んで書き取り練習を
やりましたけど
級が上がるごとに
ちょっと難しくなったり
出題文字数も増えたりして
通常の勉強方法はダメになりました
でも そこで気づいた
目標は
ゲーム感覚で目指すなら
勉強自体にもちょっぴり
遊びを入れればどうかな
漢字はただの文字ではない
漢字にはストーリーがあります
そして漢字は触っちゃいかんものではない
漢字をパズルやおもちゃとして
分解して遊ぶこともできます
漢字はただの絵ではない
漢字はアートなので
自分のイマジネーションで
本当の美しさ
本当の面白さを
引き出すこともできます
漢字は苦労して丸暗記するものではない
漢字を恐れずに
遊び心いっぱいで
楽しもう
もし
あなたが困難にぶつかった時には
その問題点の見方を
変えてみてください
私のように
その答えは 見つかるはずです
（拍手）